our subject for today trust in god very
simple what did i say trust in god
the lord is my shepherd
i shall not want
he maketh me to lie down in green
pastures
he leadeth me beside the still waters
he restoreth my soul
he leadeth me in the paths of
righteousness for his name's sake
yeah though i walk through the valley of
the shadow of death
i will fear no evil
for thou art with me
thy rod
thy staff they comfort me
thou preparest a table before me in the
presence of mine enemies thou anointest
my head with oil my cup runneth over
surely goodness and mercy shall follow
me all the days of my life
and i will dwell in the house of the
lord
forever
there's an echo but i believe the
experts will work on that to try to
eliminate it happy sabbath everyone
god is good
all the time
psalm 100 verse 5 for the lord is
good
his mercy is everlasting and his truth
endureth to all generations and in first
corinthians 13 verse 7 the bible says
that god rejoiceth not in iniquity but
rejoiceth in the truth
let me pause on that
god rejoices
truth is practiced
error practiced sincere
is still error
good intentions are not enough
god rejoiceth not in iniquity
joyceth in the truth and so psalm 105
says his mercy is everlasting psalm 100
verse 5 and his truth endureth to all
generations which means that one day
error will come to an end
along with those who persist in living
their lives by error
let me say that again
one day error
will come to an end
along with those who persist in living
their lives
by error so we thank god for truth can
you say amen
what is the highest expression of truth
jesus
but you're right you're right you're
right
john 14 6 i am the way
the truth and the life
do you know all three members of the
godhead are truth
deuteronomy 32 4 a god of truth
and without iniquity john 14 6 i am the
way the truth and the life first john 5
6 the holy spirit is truth
and john 4 24 god is a spirit and they
that worship him must worship him how in
spirit and in truth if the father is
truth and the son is truth and the holy
spirit is truth those of us who call
ourselves sons and daughters of god we
are also to be children of truth
and i believe you are
that's why you were here this morning
is there anyone with us who is not a
seventh-day adventist match your hand
you are not a seventh-day adventist
raise your hand
all right perhaps that person is on the
way
may i make a gentle suggestion to you
anytime you meet
except for bold meeting and business
meeting invite someone
many years ago i was in uganda
for an evangelistic series
and i came downstairs from my room where
i was in the hotel to the lobby for some
reason i saw a young lady all
evangelists and nosy people
so i went to her how are you what's your
name while you're here she said i'm a
soldier
and i'm guarding a diplomat from another
country but i'm off duty now and one of
my colleagues is guarding the diplomat
in her room this lady was a female
soldier
then she said who are you and i told her
why i was in her country and i said to
her come to the meeting she said i'll
come but i have no transportation and i
said there's a car that comes for me at
5 30. if you're ready in the lobby i'll
take
i came she was ready we all went she
came
every
night that was about two or three
that's 18 years she came every night
finish the story
come on with faith finish the story
she got uh god bless you and keep you
young she got baptized
[Music]
i got a text from her two weeks ago she
lives in germany now
still faithful
she lost her husband to covet 19 about
six months ago
i wrote how are you saying i'm holding
on i know i've lost him i feel it but
i'm not letting go of god somebody say
amen
how did all of that happen did was do
what invite
you don't need a phd from the university
of bisbee to invite someone
do you have a university no
i was in tanzania the very next year for
a similar purpose evangelistic service
and i always look for gyms because you
need to work out to stay fit to do the
lord's work it's hard work
the receptionist at the gym who was
signing me in i said to her well i told
my was with me tell her why i'm here
because they were speaking another
language he told her and i told him tell
her i wanted to come
she came that very night the first night
opening night
she came
every night finish the story if you have
faith she got baptized
what am i trying to tell you it does not
take tremendous skill to work for god
if you have no ability whatsoever you
have a tongue you can invite someone you
have no tongue writing
are you with me as long as you're live
there's something you can do to point
someone to christ and so i offer my
polite suggestion without getting into
your business every time you meet except
for board meeting and business meeting
invite someone it may change
that person's life
all right our subject for today trust in
god very simple what did i say
trust in god what is this
what is this
what is this not
and i've gotten a lot of trouble for
this a lot of trouble people get angry
this is 2021 come on keep up with the
times it is still not a bible
but if you're using this please let it
not ring is that reasonable all right
we're serving the god of heaven and
earth can you take one of these into the
courtroom
no
and if you snuck one in and it rings
you'll go to vacation at the
government's expense are you following
me you know okay so please let's show
respect
who's the judge of all the earth favor
number two while i'm speaking pray for
me and say what lord put
the tv preach
and i've said god please
shut that man up
don't hurt him
but shut him up or her
because of what they're saying is not
biblical at all
and so you asked god to put his words in
my mouth that's based on jeremiah
chapter 1 verse 9 then the lord put
forth his hand and touched my mouth
and the lord said unto me behold
uh zacchaeus who was another thief the
word of god changed many lives
my words cannot
favor number three
think
isaiah 1 18 come now let us do what
reason together saith the lord god calls
upon you and me to reason because god is
a reasonable god
i believe i told you last night the
devil is not possible
but god
is reasonable
heads
closed
our father in heaven we thank you for
life
with all the trials and difficulties of
modern society their god
no one wants to drop dead right now
we're grateful for life father
and we recognize you as the source of
life under giver of life
if we've sinned against you forgive us
their god and grant us the power to
avoid sin like the plague
in the name of jesus christ receive us
now i pray i humble myself before you
and i ask you today god to put your
words in my mouth your spirit and my
mind and the humility of christ in my
heart that i may represent you all right
hide me behind the cross there god let
somehow those in this building see
christ and hear christ bless all those
listening online wherever they are
father be with them as much as you are
with us a special blessing on all little
children who listening and wherever
people online father who are not
seventh-day adventists are tuning in
bless them in a very particular way if
anyone under the sound of my voice has
contracted covert 19 in the name of
jesus who healed everyone who came to
him
heal those persons father
not just improvement god heal them
completely i pray in jesus name let
god's people say amen and amen
go with me to isaiah 26 what's our
subject
trust god isaiah
it's a well-known verse verse 3.
do you have that
if you have the king james version you
may say it with me thou will do up
keep him how in perfect peace
whose mind is stayed upon thee
because he trusteth in thee let's say it
again this time microscopically and try
to get some lesson out of the verse thou
will keep him stop how many people in
that express
wait a minute how many people in that
expression
two
name
thou and him
always personalize the bible
say john 3 16.
ah for god so love come on me
thou that's god
will keep him or me
in perfect peace pause
can god do that in these
times
yes do we need that yes are people
pulling the hair out yes are people
panicking yes what does the bible say i
with you in perfect pit
all these pandemic restrictions i will
do that you can do it
while you're wondering what will happen
in the next six months what will biden
do or who met you
i will keep you
what kind of peace
your blood pressure drops
your immune system goes up
huh yeah what because god has you under
control i
will keep him that's you that's me in
perfect peace whose mind
is what stay give another word for
stayed
focused remains does not move
let me use a football analogy
my favorite position on the football
field is the wide receiver
in my view there is no athlete anywhere
on the face of the earth
as skillful as a good wide receiver i
don't want to discuss secular things on
sabbath but i'm using a sim now the wide
receiver is taught to do what with his
eyes
keep his eye
on the ball now there are two or three
men coming to kill him you know that
but
the the the the training is keep your
eye in other words look the ball into
your hands
he has to be aware of where the straight
line is so he can tip
you're following me he has he doesn't he
doesn't he's not looking for the
defensive or the quarterback
he's looking at that ball
because it's going to a certain spot
at a certain time
and he has to get there and ball may be
two inches from the hands of the
defender
keep your eye
on that ball
now
thou will keep him in
perfect peace whose mind is stayed upon
thee
but we're easily distracted
so we bothered by this thing or that
thing or that thing or we fight each
other because this one supports trump
this one supports biden this one's putin
this one supports boris johnson this one
supports the antichrist
the mind must be
stayed upon whom thee who is the god
but finish the verse
because
he trusteth in thee now let's look at
trust
let's go to proverbs chapter
what's our subject
trust in god proverbs 3 let's read from
verse 5. you know it very well you can
say it without looking
but i'll let you find
to it off today i'll let you find it and
read it all right do you have it now
proverbs 3 verse 5 say it with me what
trust in the lord come on with all thine
heart stop
that's where many of us fall short
we trust in the lord how
with some of our heart
and it doesn't work
let's go to mark 11 then we'll come
mark 11 24.
23 sorry 23
mark 11 verse 23 mark is the shortest
gospel mark was not one of the twelve
disciples
who followed christ around i should say
any believer in christ as a disciple do
you have mark 11
verse 23
read with me what does that say
to you come on whosoever shall say to
this mountain be thou removed and what
cast into the
and shall not
stop
where what is christ saying there must
be
no doubt
which means 99 belief
is not enough
dwell on that for a minute
do not doubt
but we doubt
let's go to acts 8. the book of acts our
subject trust in god
it's 12 15.
well you know the adventist church is a
church of prophecy so you're based on
time
october 22 1844 we're time conscious
people somebody say amen all right so
i'm always keeping my eye on the time
because i never assume someone enjoys
what i'm saying
so let me finish quickly and ease you of
your agony all right let's go to action
do you have it
36.
when you find that say amen
let me pray again father continue to be
with me
choke my carnal nature into submission
and let me give free expression to your
word your truth you may be glorified in
jesus name i pray amen acts 8 36 what
does the bible say and
as they went on their way they came to
what a certain water it's peter and whom
the ethiopian unit
and the unit said what
see here is water what the thing to me
come on to be baptized read the words of
philip and philip said what
if believe this come on
with all thine heart
finish the words thou missed
stop that's fine
now what does prophet
say trust in the lord
with all my god
is this literal or symbolic
it is little
the bible is literal now we are people
of prophecy most of the bible is literal
and must be taken literally
unless it is obviously symbolic and i
stood up on the sand of the sea and saw
a rising sea having seven heads and ten
horns we know that's symbolic
trust in the lord with all thine heart
what is that literal
and lean not until thy known
understanding
come on say that again for me in
saying it but you don't believe it in
all thy ways your financial life your
social life your educational life your
romantic life say amen
that amen was lifeless but i'll take it
in all thy ways
acknowledge god
are you in university studying college
high school community college you're
studying biology acknowledge god
you're studying accounting acknowledge
god
you're studying history acknowledge god
because all branches of legitimate
knowledge originate with god
in all ways
acknowledge him
finish the verse
and he
shall direct thy path this is what we
need we've always needed it but in these
times of pandemic restrictions and
uncertainty and job loss and all
the anxiety that is caused because when
we cannot control we get anxious
forgetting
that it's god's job to control our job
to trust
in all thy ways
acknowledge him
and he shall direct
thy paths
literal let me give an example of
someone's path directed by god go with
me to genesis 39
what's our subject trust in god
and we'll come back to isaiah 26 and to
proverbs 3.
how do i trust in god
genesis 39
joseph is brought to egypt who bought
him
potiphar a captain of the pharaoh an
officer of pharaoh captain of guard
bottom of the hands of the ishmaelites
which had brought him down thither verse
two read with me and the lord come on
was with joseph come on and he was a
prosperous man and he was in the house
of his master the egyptian the bible
says the lord was with joseph
was a prosperous man verse 3
and his master saw
that the lord was with him stop
if you're with god someone should see it
is this mike working okay
if you say you're christian someone
should notice it if the unbeliever
doesn't notice it you're not a christian
you may be a church member
let me say it again it is the unbeliever
that recognizes you live a different
life not the church member
because all church members we all know
we have to behave a certain way on
sabbath so we perform we all look like
the high priest
but the unbeliever must recognize
because the power of christ in you must
be so strong stretch the unbeliever he
may not know it's christ he'll simply
know there's something different about
that man
so potiphar is deliberately called the
egyptian to contrast him with joseph who
was hebrew and master
saw that the lord was with him now you
finish that verse
come on verse 3
and said the lord come on
made
all that he did to prosper stop
who was responsible for the results
joseph enjoyed
god
do you run a business
give it to god
let him produce results
that heaven can acknowledge
there are two kinds of results honest
and dishonest
we have no interest in dishonest results
they end when you die
honest results continue to the kingdom
timothy tells us well paul tells us
godliness is profitable unto all things
having promise of the life that now is
and of the life to come first timothy 4
8 godliness is profitable in
all things you're running a business run
it righteously christ object lessons
49 paragraph 3 element writes business
and religion are not two separate things
they are the one
and the lord was with joseph and he was
a prosperous man and he was in the house
of his mastered egyptian
and his master saw
that the lord was with him and that the
lord made all that he did not some
everything joseph turned touched turned
to gold why he trusted in god and god
became responsible for the results
don't take class on sabbath honor god's
sabbath
but every other way
god be responsible for your results as
he blesses your heart study god does not
bless laziness somebody say amen
joseph
now
go to verse 23 now joseph is in prison
for having done nothing wrong
come my dear brother come
you're replacing this
partner all right
give them time to find verse 23
this is 39.
thank you god bless you in every
possible way my handsome brother
let's pray for heaven we thank you for
improved equipment let the words go
forth clearly i pray that you may be
glorified and your people blessed in
jesus name amen
read verse 23 for me what does that say
the keeper of the prison uh-huh
look not to anything come on
that was at his hand come on
because the lord was with him and
that which he did
the lord made it to prosper it had no
choice
you're very nice people you say mercy
and amen are you following me
that which he did
the lord
made it to prosper
because the lord
was with joseph
joseph trusted god we see that when part
of his wife who has been attractive and
shapely and she said lie with me joseph
said no
no and you ran away
trusting god
now let's go back to isaiah 26.
what's our subject
trust in god
before we read well let's go to isaiah
verse 3.
if you don't know that verse memorize it
please
and when you're troubled say it
and believe it
are you there
read with me thou will keep him
in perfect peace whose mind is stayed
upon thee because he trusteth in thee
the question arose earlier i bring it
back how do we trust in god
fully yes
but what's the method by which what's
the instrument by which we trust in god
when you trust in god what are you
saying tell me what are you saying
you have faith in him
do you believe he exists
how do you know that
the word told you are you following me
when you say i trust in god in my
sickness do you believe god can heal you
how do you know god heals
the word
when you're burdened by guilt and you
ask for forgiveness and you believe god
forgave you how do you know god forgives
the word now how do you trust in god the
word
believe what he says
it makes all the sense in the world to
believe god why is that how many of you
have ever submitted a cv in applying for
a job
cv
what do you call it
resume all right i repent i repent i
repent resume some people call it cv
curriculum vita
what is god's tv
resume
what is god's resume come on
all right yes but let's condense it when
you send a resume you don't send an
encyclopedia are you following me you
send one page are you with me what is
god's resume
someone says the ten commandments
that's what it requires we want to know
what he has done that's what your resume
says
genesis
chapter one
is god's rest aha
it's god's resume
you see the bible does not introduce god
as a savior how is god introduced
a creator
when sin is all done and there is no
need for savior will we still have a
creator yes will we still have a savior
no
the role of savior came in because of a
catastrophe called sin
but had there never been sin there would
have been no savior no cross no
calvary always as a creator
now let's go to genesis one let's read
from verse one what's your subject
trust in god
25 to 12.
don't look at the clock i won't look
i'll just guess all right genesis 1
reading from first one do you have that
read it with me by looking up don't look
at that bible look up
say genesis 1 1. in the beginning god
created the heaven and the earth now you
can look down and the earth was without
form and void and darkness was upon the
face of the deep and the spirit of god
moved upon the face of the waters now
look at verse 2 again the earth was
without form that's
and void the reform means chaotic
void means no life
are you with me
chaotic
no life
question for you is society right now
somewhat chaotic
yes
everywhere people are protesting the
restrictions life is chaotic do you know
what's happening at the border down
south
chaotic
in congress is chaos
the earth was without form chaotic now
how does god solve chaos let's look at
verse 3
and god stop
the word
and god
said
what did he say
let there be light what happened
now pause let me ask you this you all
look like reasonable people
if you met someone
whose word is so powerful
that the word says
let there be light and it's midnight
wherever that lady was coast guard ran
for three days with no gas
dark or three hours okay three days
we are people of faith okay
it's dark and someone walks up and says
let there be light and light flashed all
over the place
what would you say to that person
and then the person says to you can you
trust my word what would you say yes
the bible introduces god
as someone who functions by his
word the bible tells us that the word of
god is absolutely reliable
what it says
it does
what did it say let there be
what happened there was light now take
that same word
that same power and listen to it bring
you all the tithe into the storehouse
that they maybe meet in my house and
prove me now here with save the lord of
hosts if i will not open you the windows
of heaven and pour you out
that there shall not be room enough to
receive it that is as powerful as let
there be like and there was light
because it's the same person who's
spoken
god's cv
is creation
a resume
resume creation
look at verse 6
of genesis 1.
read it
stop stop look at verse 9.
look at verse 11.
look at 14.
look at 20.
look at 24.
look at 26.
stop what is the holy ghost trying to
tell you
this
is how god does
everything
now
to doubt god
it's the doubt he created
do you understand why doubting god is
such an insult to god
you look at the universe of which you
are apart
you walk in the grass made by the word
of god genesis 1 11 let the earth bring
forth grass you ate the fruits from the
trees the fruit tree yielding seed
you inhale the air let there be a
firmament
you drink the water
let the waters under the heavens be
gathered together into one place
you have pets let the earth bring forth
the living creature after it's kind you
have friends let us make man you look
around you live in a world created by
thus saith the lord and then god says to
you will you believe will you trust me
and we say no
let me ask you this
am i being too hard on you
okay
okay all right
how did god create the entire universe
his word good
can that god
exercise the same power to help you keep
the sabbath yes or no yes
if god can make a universe can he not
take care of your little world yes
what is isaiah what is that proverbs 3
verse 5 says
trust in the lord with all thine heart
all of it so that when you come across
an impossibility
you think of and god said
let there be light
and there was light and in the face of
an impossibility you trust god
go to genesis 11.
genesis 11
it's 12 30 i'm not supposed to look at
the clock but habits are hard to break
sorry sister
genesis 11 let's read verse 30. are you
there
okay one on this person said no okay
most people say yes and they're not yet
there
genesis 11
do you have that
let's go to verse 30.
do you have it
let me pray father
remind me i'm here for your glory not
mine
grant me the spirit of truth not opinion
in jesus name i pray amen
read verse 30 for me
but serie i
was barren come on she had no cha what
does barren mean
unable to have children in
fertile
we learned this in chapter 11.
now
a barren woman it is impossible for her
come on to have a child good
go to genesis 12.
let's read from verse 1.
have you found it
now the lord had said unto abram
get thee out of thy country and from thy
kindred and from thy father's house unto
a land that i will show thee and i will
make of thee a great nation but what
kind of wife did he have
a very life but god says to him because
god believes in one man one wife
ah come on say amen
therefore shall a man
leave his father
and his mother and shall cleave to his
wife two singular words
and they twin
shall be one flesh i don't care what
your culture says
this says
one man
one woman
and
god put adam in the sleep took one of
his ribs closed up the flesh instead
thereof and the rib which the lord had
taken from man made he a woman and
brought her unto the man god put a man
and a woman together not a boy and a
girl are you following me
too many boys want girlfriends finish my
words and too many girls want boyfriends
god put a man
with a woman
not a boy and a girl
parents
teach that to your children
never rush to get out of childhood
why do you want to start paying taxes
are you with me don't rush to get out of
childhood it only lasts about 18 years
and if it's three score and ten you have
52 years of paying the government and
doing this and worrying enjoy your
childhood
are you with me
all right let's go back to genesis 12.
reading for stu read with me and i will
make of thee a great nation and i will
bless thee and make thy name great and
thou shall be a blessing now got old
tells abraham you'll be the father of
many many seeds but his wife could not
have children what was abraham facing on
impossibility
verse 15 genesis 15
our subject
trust in god
with how much of our heart
all of it and god does not change that
standard all of it genesis 15 reading
from verse 1. do you have that
if you have my version read for me what
is it saying
after these things the word of lord came
unto abram in a vision saying what fear
lord abram i am thy shield and the
exceeding great reward
and abram said what lord god
what will thou give me seeing i go
childless and the steward of my house is
this eliezer of damascus what is ibrahim
saying he wanted to make eliezer his
heir
because he realized what
sarah could not have children and he
only had one wife
and so he said this elias of damascus is
mine heir and he said behold to me thou
has given no
verse three know what
and lord one born in my house come on is
mine heir he goes back to elias again
and the word of the lord came unto him
saying what verse 4 read before me
this
the word of lord came to him saying this
shall not be thine heir keep reading but
he that shall come forth out of thine
own bowels shall be thine egg what god
meant was the child that comes from the
union of you and sarah
don't tell me sarah can't have children
that's a human problem not a divine
problem
verse 5
and he brought him forth abroad and said
what
look now toward heaven and tell the
stars if thou be able to number them and
he said unto him what so shall thy seed
be god is i know your wife cannot have
children let me tell you something
god is called the god of abraham come on
isaac come on jacob abraham's wife could
not have children isaac's wife could not
have children jacob's favorite wife
could not have children
god is not a comedian god wants a people
who serve him based on trust
and sometimes he puts you in a situation
where you have to trust him
to remind you of your human helplessness
and so abraham's wife couldn't have
children isaac's wife couldn't have
children jacob's number one wife
couldn't have children and god is called
the god of abraham isaac and jacob he's
the god of those who trust him
in the face of impossibility
we know god had isaac abraham at isaac
when when they could not go to romans 4.
now what's your subject
trust in god romans chapter four
do you have romans
who wrote the book of romans
very good paul
eloise said paul was the second greatest
teacher who ever lived
who was the first
god bless you for that
romans chapter 4 reading verse 19.
this is about abraham do you have it
you have my version
read with me what's this saying
and being not weak in faith come on
he considered not his own body
now dead keep reading
neither yet the dead when he was about
100 years old neither yet the deadness
of sarah's womb stop
how many dead conditions do we have in
that verse
two name them
abraham's loins come on and sarah's womb
dead
now nothing gets more impossible than
raising the dead for a human being
are you following me
how do people behave at funerals and i'm
being very respectful i've lost my
father my mother father-in-law
mother-in-law my young brother my
spiritual brother i've suffered a lot of
loss
this is not how do people behave a
funeral they cry why
if you could raise your relative who
passed would you be crying
no you just say get up
here's someone
in opera condition operable condition in
the hospital i see you you have six
hours to live and you gathered around
the bed and you're crying
because there's nothing you can do
sometimes god puts us in situations
where there is nothing we can do so that
we lift our eyes and we recognize that
god can do everything the things which
are impossible with men
are possible with god and so we have
deadlines
abraham was over the hill
sarah dead wound
what can be done with two states of
death
read verse 20.
what does that say
he staggered not in what unbelief come
on
he staggered not in
at the promise of god what was god's
promise
you'll have children
now you need to appreciate the point
that abraham had reached in his faith
he's aware the bible says he considered
not his own body
now
dead when he was about a hundred years
old
neither yet the deadness of cyril zoom
what do you understand by he considered
not his own body now dead what do you
understand by that
he didn't worry about it
it was not his focus
there's a biblical principle that works
positively and negatively go to 2nd
corinthians 3 let's read verse 18 then
we come back to romans 4 20.
ii corinthians chapter 3 verse 18.
do you have that
not yet
second corinthians who wrote second
corinthians
but who wrote first corinthians
yes
i just can't fool you okay second
corinthians 3 verse 18 do you have that
has anyone said lord put your words in
that man's mouth has anyone prayed that
prayer nobody oh
god bless you i really appreciate i mean
that sincerely god bless you of those
who have not yet done it please do it
before i say amen
read for me verse 18 of second
corinthians 3 but we all come on
with open face
beholding us and what do you mean what
do you understand by beholding
looking at give another word is stronger
than looking
focus give me another word sounds like
looking but it's stronger than looking
starts with an s then a t then an a then
an r how many clues do you need staring
staring
you know you
there are some menstrual women who are
in tight tight pants as though they were
painted on they're staring
we all with open face
beholding us in a glass what the glory
of the lord come on are changed into the
same image from glory to glory what does
that tell us what you look at
ah
god bless that nice person who said that
what you stare at
you become
now keep this in mind go back to romans
4 20 verse 19. go back to romans 4 verse
19. keep in mind what you stare at you
become what you behold you become
go back to romans 4 19 now and let's
read microscopically and think
are you at 19 is romans 4
with me and being not
weak in faith he come on he considered
not what does that mean
he did not
give me the word i've been using he did
not
no he did not
he did not stare at his problem
then he was looking somewhere else are
you with me are you not with me
he did not stare at the problem
he must be looking somewhere else
he considered not his own body that's
not what he focused neither yet the
deadness of syrian womb he did not focus
on the fact his laws were dead and his
wife's womb was there he was focusing on
god because what you focus on changes
you
i hope you're following me
if you keep looking at your problem
it grows
look somewhere else
because what you stare at will affect
you
you're not following me you're not
following me
that's why some people stay depressed
they just stare
they just stare at the fact that this
woman took my boyfriend from me twice
in the same month twice
so she stares at that and gets depressed
and gets depressed and forgets god can
find another man 10 times better
[Music]
he considered not his own body
now dead he looked somewhere else
neither he had the deadness of sarah's
womb he looked somewhere else
read verse 20 now for me what does that
say
he staggered not
at the promise of god
ah
wait a minute how do you describe a man
who's staggering
how does he walk
he's stumbling
abraham walked
upright
despite the physical
impossibilities he was dealing with his
dead womb his deadline the wife's dead
wound he did not
shift from what god said
he grew into that you don't get that
automatically he grew into that he
staggered not at the promise of god
through unbelief keep reading but was
strong in faith come on
ah
giving glory to god why would he give
glory to god because he came to the
place where he believed despite his
wife's condition and his condition he
would have a child
so he began thanking god before the
child was born ah come on
this is going over your heads
are you getting it
this side is getting it what happened to
you
he staggered not at the promise of god
through unbelief but was strong in faith
giving glory to god now as a church
family read verse 21
[Music]
and being what
stop
fully persuaded what does that remind
you of
proverbs 3 verse 5
come on what does it say
trust in the lord
oh my heart
does that remind you of isaiah 26 3 that
will keep him in perfect peace whose
mind is stayed upon thee does that
remind you philip to the unite if thou
believers with all thine heart does that
remind you of christ in mark 11 23 if
thou say to this mountain be thou
removed and be cast into the sea and
shall not doubt in your heart
he was fully persuaded
finish that verse 21.
what he had promised come on
now if he if god could create a universe
can he not solve your problem
your focus must not be the pandemic
the restrictions
who's in the white house
or the blue house
your focus must be who is on the throne
above
are you with me
and we know what happened when abraham
was an old man
he had a son
sarah had the same son
that is why isaac is the son of faith
the only son god recognized spiritually
so when god called abraham to sacrifice
his son here's what god said and it came
to pass after these things that god
attempted abraham and said unto him
abraham and he said here i am and he
said take now thy son thine only son
because isaac was the son of faith
whatsoever is not of faith
is sin
what's our subject
i have a question for you do you trust
god
what's the only way to trust god
his word
you know that's one of the names of
jesus the word yes
what a revelation 19.
it's a quarter to one
revelation 19 let's read verse 13.
i should say i'm enjoying myself with
you god bless you
i really am since last night today god
bless you i really am i get the
impression you love the word of god i
could be wrong but i get that impression
am i right or wrong
okay what book did i say
why are you taking so long to find
revelation
revelation 19 let's read verse 13 do you
have that
let me pray again father i'm coming to
the close of this message but do not
shut off your help i pray in jesus name
amen read verse 13 for me what does it
say and he
was clothed
with a vesture dipped in blood finish
the first and his name is called what
the word of god this is the name of
jesus the word at his highest is jesus
himself
now let me introduce you to a crime many
of us commit
by not believing god's word it's a
serious crime
go to first john 5. it's a serious crime
you and i need to repent
first john 5.
let's read nine and ten
you have that
my king james people read with me so i
can understand what you're saying what
does this say if
we receive the witness of men the
witness of god is
keep reading for this is the
which he hath
of his
all right now
god give a witness of his son listen to
verse 10 now read for me he that
believeth
come on start again he that believeth
aha
have the witness in himself he that
believeth not carefully now
has made
a liar why
because he believeth not the record god
gave of his son where is that record
right here the bible says when you doubt
god's word you're calling god
let me tell you who a liar is and then
you put two and two together
go to john 8
verse 44. god bless you
john 8 44.
this is very serious i hope it shakes
you up
so that you and i can make some changes
in how we view god
john 8 verse 44. this is jesus speaking
now
let me know when you found it
who's still looking
read with me ye are of your father the
devil
pause not all people belong to god
some belong
to the devil even though they attend
church
because god christ was speaking to
church members are you listening to me
the people who said crucify him were
very faithful church members
that's not an argument against church it
simply means the wheat and the tares
grow the same place are you following me
year of your father the devil and the
lusts of your father you will do he was
a murderer from the beginning and abode
not in the truth because there is no
truth in him but jesus says i'm the
truth are you with me the father is
truth deuteronomy 32 4 the holy ghost is
truth first john 5 6 there is no truth
in satan keep reading when he speaketh a
lie he speaketh of himself in other
words it's his natural language for he
is a liar stop
the bible says who is a liar satan but
go back to first john 5 read verse 10.
come on finally quickly
we have a potluck to take care of
[Music]
do you have first john 5 10. read with
me now he that
believeth come on
on the son of god
hath the witness in himself uh-huh
he that believeth not have made him
stop but who is a liar
then what are we calling god when we
doubt him
satan
you're virtually accusing god of satanic
behavior
that's the unpardonable sin
because when jesus healed the man
possessed by the devil the pharisees
said this fellow does not cast out
devils but by belgium of the prince of
devils he charged jesus with using power
of satan
that's why jesus said every idle word
that was an idle word
when we doubt god's word in the presence
of clear evidence
we are virtually calling god finish my
words a liar
none of us wants to do that
what's your subject
what's the only way to trust in god
his word
how much trust does god require
trust in the lord with
say it again
one more time
how many people say father
forgive me for my weak faith help me to
grow and trust to like trust you with
all my heart can i see your hand uh do
you mean that do you mean that stand up
with me
someone may want to say lord having
heard this message today and last night
i really want to recommit my life to you
recommit my life 100
and be serious
if you're that person can i see your
right hand
keep it up
father in heaven
we thank you for the convicting power of
your word
we thank you for your people gathered in
your presence father in my estimation
they love your word and they love you
i joined them and saying forgive us for
having weak faith please god we do not
want to call you a liar
we trust a god who said let there be
light and there was light you were
introduced as a creator who functions by
his word father and all throughout
eternity you'll be a creator
we thank you for your word that cannot
be broken by god
it gives life and alawite writes the
creative energy that called the worlds
into existence is in the word of god
this word imparts power it begets life
every command is a promise accepted by
the will received into the soul it
brings with it the life of the infinite
one it transforms the nature and
recreates the soul in the image of god
father help us to believe that word for
in believing the word we believe you
help us to look at conditions and smile
because we know our father has
everything under control let us not
stare at the pandemic let us stare at
you
because what we behold changes us
then let our calm spirit put someone
else at ease
bless us the rest of this day i pray
in jesus name let god's people say amen
and amen you may be seated